hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the norway chess 2021 we have a
very very interesting game between yani
punish and magnus carlsen and this is
already the armageddon the classical
game ended in a fairly quick draw it was
a nice joko piano of course if nepo had
went for the uh evans gambit things
might have been a bit different but of
course we can't just uh
gambit everything on that uh one game so
now we have the armageddon uh nipple
needs a win with white magnus only needs
a draw to win the match nipple has ten
minutes and o'clock magnus seven let's
see what happens uh with the white
pieces nipple opens with e4 we have e5
by magnus and knight to c3 going for the
vienna game uh knight to c6 and now not
the immediate f4 but first bishop the c4
uh we have knight to f6 and now d3
defending the the pawn one more time
also preparing to develop the light uh
the dark square bishop we have knight to
a5 attacking nepal's bishop and c4
bishop to b3 and magnus captures on b3
we have eight captures on b3 ended now
striking in the center with d5 so we
have a trade e captures knight captures
and now we have a queen to h5 saying
okay i'm threatening to capture the the
pawn on e5 it's undefended uh what do
you play uh magnus says you uh have that
pawn i'm just going to play knight to b4
and threaten knight captures on c2 with
check so nipple capture that we have
queen captures an e5 with check and not
just the bishop to e7 so uh straight out
pawn sacrifice for magnus right out of
the opening uh we have queen back to e2
and now comes castles you don't want
your queen to be anywhere you know deep
into the game and also you have to have
the c2 pawn defended uh and now there is
one game where vastly manchu defeated
shadow in 2012 world blitz final uh
where queen to d1 was played by manchu
but here we have bishop to e3 and it is
now only as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game now makes sense you
want to continue development uh and also
uh rook to e8 is coming so this bishop
will come in handy here so this is
exactly what magnus plays knight to f3
preparing castles and now just a5
cementing this knight here on b4 uh we
have h3 preventing bishop to g4 and now
b6 by magnus magnus has the bishop pair
he sacrificed the pawn but the bishop
pair will be very nice compensation
so castles and now bishop to b7 uh we
have rook eight to see one now now you
will be able to move the knight and then
start advancing these pawns uh so bishop
to f6 and now d4 uh and here
uh what do you do uh well the the bishop
pair is definitely better uh white is up
upon but it's not easy to play and
it's uh it's so much better that magnus
even avoids playing bishop to a6 now i
don't know if this is a blunder if he
missed this uh because who amongst us
would not play this or do they just both
agree that the light square bishop is
just such a monster of a piece that it's
uh you know it would be pointless to
give it up for for this rook that's
doing pretty much nothing on f1 so the
engine very much enjoys this but for uh
such a quick game maybe maybe the bishop
is to be preferred or it was a case of
mutual blindness we don't know until we
uh see at least an interview with um one
of them but okay rook after d1
uh sorry
not bishop to a6 uh we have queen to d7
now by magnus just continuing
development uh and now uh rook f the d1
so now maybe nipple spotted it maybe not
maybe he just wants to get the knight
out of the way play c4 d5 and so on so
rook a to d8 and now queen to b5 nepo is
now ready to trade queens and then he
wants to have some sort of an end game
where he moves the knight and start push
starts pushing this uh c pawn and d pawn
so queen to c8 magnus avoids the trade
but nepo very resourcefully finds a way
on how to achieve it still so queen to
h5 now you might run into some trouble
here
if knight to g5 you might give up
you might have to give up the bishop
so maybe not something to to go for
so instead we have h6 but now queen to
g4 and now you have to trade queens uh
there's really nothing better to do also
ideas like bishop captures and h6 are in
the position so here magnus just trades
this doubles neapo um uh well h to g
pawn now uh and rook to d7 now he wants
to double up on the d file and put some
pressure on the d4 pawn so rook to d2 by
nippo and now g5 by magnus we have
knights to d1 and rook d back to d8 we
have c3 now chasing away this knight
knight to d5 and knight the h2 all right
we have king to g7 bringing the king
into the game knights to f1 and now king
to g6 by magnus so yes this is how deep
into the game you have to bring your
king for maximum activity we have f3
and now h5 magnus now wants to open up
the h file maybe he can get some action
along the h file if he doubles rooks
here maybe you know good things might
happen
so g captures an h5 king captures an h5
and now comes bishop to f2 king to f2
also may be a possibility
but he wants to play fast magnus is down
to some two and a half minutes on the
clock nip or some five minutes on the
clock and magnus just goes back king to
g6
we have knight beat the e3 and now
bishop back to e7 now the bishop can be
shifted over to
maybe d6 uh we have knight captures on
d5 bishop captures on d5 and now c4 so
now nipple will start expanding his pawn
structure here in the center bishop back
to e6 d5 now but now before reacting to
this magnus first uh throws in a nice
fishing suit attacks the rook here so
rook back to d1 and now bishop back to
d7 we have knight to e3 and now we have
f5 grabbing more space here and now you
can start pushing f4 and g4 knight to c2
uh puts pressure on the bishop here and
the magnus of course saves it uh he
didn't sacrifice upon to just give up
the bishop pair like this and now the
bishops are almost optimally placed the
pawns are ready to be pushed and if the
rooks become operational as well uh good
things might happen but that's an if and
never still up a pawn
so here we have knights to d4 uh and now
comes g4 by magnus we have g3 by nipple
and now you could go with f4 and create
some absolute chaos here but maybe it's
a bit too complicated to go into it so a
little time on the clock so magnus goes
for this
g captures on f3 it's much easier to uh
to just see everything because the
knight now captures and then you gain
this e2 square for your rook so knight
captures on f3 rook to e2 and now rook
to d2 going for the trade
magnus of course captures we have
captures captures and the rook to e8 now
the other rook wants to come to e2 so
rook to d1 also rook to e1 possible but
uh nipple needs a win so trading the
other pair of rooks as well uh he he
kind of well he's not going to get that
win so f4 by magnus and now we trade uh
this last pawn on the king side g
captures bishop captures and now knight
to f3
and now the rook is here nicely giving
support to this pawn but it's very hard
to create something here because these
spawns are nicely controlling these
pawns uh so rook sorry rook to e2 uh
just nicely going after that b2 pawn uh
and now comes bishop to d4 just
defending the pawn and what does magnus
do here he plays bishop to g4 it's a
very nice move attacks the knight and
also kind of x-rays that rook on d1 so
here we have rook to f1 defending the
knight and now the position is so close
to winning but you have to play a very
precise move here so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
while i check out a checkup under under
upper versus ferrugia game
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh well always
bringing your king deeper into the game
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course king to f5
and of course you guys found this
because you are a great end game players
and now we're threatening uh just
captures rook captures and then we can
bring our king over to
uh the e4 with an attack on the rook and
under bishop so what do you play here
well the kind of the the strongest
defense here is just rook f2 but it's
still it's still ugly rook captures on
f2 now you have to deliver this knight
to h4 check and then king to e4 not
going after the knight because the
bishop captures rook defends the knight
so here we have to go for activity
bishop captures nf2 and now bishop to d1
and now we are going to be very happy
here grabbing those pawns and the black
should have a winning advantage but
nipple tried the active d6 move uh and
uh it seems that he kind of scared
magnus because magnus played c
characters on the e6 when in fact you
have to go for king to e4 and it's
pretty much the same idea the knight is
attacked twice the bishop hangs and
whatever you play let's say knight to
the e5 we still win the piece captures
captures captures and now this is
nothing because the bishop covers the
queening square you don't have anything
here with white but nepal managed to
trick magnus somehow and the magnus
played just c captures on d6 he of
course enjoys his position still it's
it's a much better position so not even
this is a problem and probably he didn't
want to waste time uh
calculating because yes they've reached
time 40 they do get additional time for
every move but it's only one second so
here we have bishop catrice and b6 and
now bishop captures an f3 again king to
e for the absolute strongest but here
bishop captures on f3 was played rook
captures and now rook captures and b2 we
have bishop to d4 attacking carlson's
rook now rook to b1 check king to f2
and now finally king to e4 we have
bishop to g7 getting this bishop out of
the way but now the position is winning
for magnus as now there is a very
specific trick in the position so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that yes
the white king is in the mating web and
if uh
he doesn't wish to get checkmated he
will have to give up the rook of course
white doesn't want to do neither so rook
the h1 congratulations to everyone who
found this you are
once again in this a spectacular end
game player and now the threat is the
simple rook to h3 check we're going to
have to step back from the defense of
our rook on f3 and that's it the king
captures rook and it's game over so rook
the c3 the only square available to this
rook but it's not a problem rook the h2
with check we have kink the f1 king the
g1 is more precise but uh now this is
you know uh it's armageddon everything
is more precise so bishop to e3 now uh
just going for this king to f3 and then
it will be impossible to defend against
checkmate temple played c5 d captures on
c5 rook the c4 check king to f3 and he
was in this position on mu 56 that yanni
pony should resign to the game and a
victory for magnus carlsen in the
armageddon which now means uh that uh
magnus is the winner of um
of the tournament uh rapport could have
i believe equalized with points but uh
uh well i don't want to spoil anything
for you as uh the game is still going on
perhaps uh and i'm gonna cover that game
next uh so we're gonna discuss that but
yeah uh like 99 magnus won the
tournament we'll see what happens but
yeah after king to f3 nepal resigned uh
as there is nothing more to be done here
rook to h1 will be checkmate and there's
no way to stop this there's there's
really no way
so that's the game armageddon is always
is cruel hope you guys uh enjoyed that
uh i would like to thank uh or rather
wish a happy birthday to matthew tebute
uh i would like to thank uh philippe
giorgio uh dimitry sampson of john
dukedale and uh author fun faceoff for a
contribution uh to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank all for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the uh furuga rapport game as i know you
guys are expecting that one uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day